qué estamos haciendo ahora como
industria financiera que se va a alinear
los compromisos de productividad de
caños financieros con los compromisos de
preservación y restauración ambiental
entonces usted no sólo soy arreglamos un
nuevo acuerdo que conservaremos regiones
de biomas amazónicos de cerrado y de
chaco que son idiomas muy importantes
para nosotros en latinoamérica que
conectan nuestros países
y que harán toda la diferencia en un
futuro más verde de una economía más
conectada con la preservación ambiental
que estamos haciendo ahora es empezar un
nuevo ciclo de acá de riqueza que es
paseado no de la competición con la
natural naturaleza pero pero ha paseado
en la naturaleza creo que eso tiene que
ha sido la mayor conquista la más
importante conquista hoy acá en kobe 26
ahora josé una de las noticias más
importantes tiene que ver con que los
líderes mundiales se comprometieron a
frenar la deforestación para el año 2030
como cree usted no como experto en el
tema que puede contribuir la
agroindustria en este sentido
perfecto yo creo que bajo industria
puede ser la heroína de todo eso no la
enemiga de la preservación ambiental
creo que sea posible alinear producción
con preservación pero para que eso
ocurra tenemos que tener las ventajas
necesarias a las entero al ranchero para
que haga la diferencia
así que se ingresa al mercado financiero
que puede proveer concreto más adecuado
para los los productores rurales y la
agroindustria para que él puede hacer la
transición para una economía más fuerte
es eso que estamos haciendo ahora con
ifa que es el compromiso que fue ha
señalado y entonces pues muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en france 24